for those of you who might have seen i
posted on instagram about my love for
this
brand and that's why i'm really thrilled
to
officially announce that i'm the new
face of garnier whole blue
well you may noticed a honey theme
happening here
in the kitchen and that's because at
garnier whole blends
we're all about supporting the bee
conservancy
they're a non-profit organization that
protects 10
million bees and to celebrate hall
blends clean initiative
with their new sulfate free remedy
collection
we thought we would get a little dirty
first with a new segment we are calling
coming clean with garnier whole blends
i answer some pretty crazy ones in this
take a look
hey mr daniel i love this yellow
[Applause]
all right you know when you come to a
salon it's all about spilling the tea
right
so we're gonna play a little game called
come and clean with
garnier holblin so i'm going to ask you
a series of questions they're going to
start really easy
but then they're going to get a lot
harder okay okay
for every dirty little question you're
willing to answer mr daniel is going to
pump some
more shampoo into your hair the goal is
to get as much shampoo as we possibly
can
on to you okay and if you need any more
incentive
for every question that you're willing
to answer we're going to give a vff
a 50 gift card to walmart okay okay
well now i want to answer everything
well we'll see i mean some of these are
kind of personal
true okay you ready for your first
question i'm so ready
question number one if you drop some
food on the floor
please still eat it yes yeah thank you
thank you honesty
have you ever used your name to get a
reservation at a restaurant yeah
yeah but i usually like have
someone else call and do it because i'm
so embarrassed
that i don't have this fine to drop it
myself
have you ever purposely cried just to
get out of something
oh for sure more when i was younger
now i just can't help crying and my
daughter's like oh
mom but when i was younger sure
all right i've gone easy on you with
some of these questions
it's about to go into high gear all
right let's do it
drew how long have you gone without
shaving your legs oh
like moths i hate shaving my legs i
finally just did it yesterday
can we do a little more shampoo yeah
yeah she answered
more shampoo you're doing great drew
thank you rossie
wait until you smell this
[Music]
tough one here have you ever been skinny
dipping
duh yeah i love a good kitty dick for
yes i love skinny dipping it's so fun
maybe it's like more of a girl thing
i definitely do that with girlfriends my
daughters
like just off with the clothes and into
the water
this took a turn
what's the craziest thing you ever saw
at studio 54
i feel like i was so young at studio 54
it was really clubs like limelight
and like a few years later it got crazy
it was so fun i'd see grace jones and
such fun
people watching let's see if she'll
answer this one
when you're being intimate with somebody
are you
um are you a lights on or off kind of
person
so i'm very weird about lighting i like
really i like natural light from the day
or like very soft
lights um i'm very lighting sensitive so
in any scenario
okay last question have you ever like
totally got it on
in a car wrong
i know what happened
i'm like wrong
that was so much fun i can honestly say
that i've
never felt cleaner i answered seven
questions which means seven vffs but
because
garnier holblins is available at walmart
right now
all of the bffs are also getting a 50
walmart gift card i know thank you
guardian
i highly suggest purchasing one of these
beautiful products and anything else
that you may see fit
thank you garnier whole blends i am so
proud and humbled to be your girl
you